l'eau du fleuve c'est cool calmement
entre québec et lévis tout le contraire
du débat sur le troisième bien plus
animée que jamais parmi ce groupe de
pêcheurs
fava est intéressant pour la ville de
québec qu'il y aurait bien plus facile
basler janvier 1.6 aval à montréal fait
que j'aime mieux le voir dans ma cour
que dakota voisins on était moins payée
sauf pour certains même un milliard ça
serait démesuré comme solution mais je
n'ai 10 chez les environnementalistes
par contre la cause est déjà entendue le
tunnel québec lévis doit compter quatre
voies de circulation automobile contre
deux qui seront réservées aux autobus
si la caq promet de favoriser le
transfert des usagers de la rive sud
vers le futur tramway de québec
c'est d'abord pour verdir un projet
autoroutier c'est pas parce que c'est
tanguy transport collectif qu'il faut
faire n'importe quoi pour avoir le
meilleur investissement possible pour le
nombre d'usagers qu'on est capable
d'emmener dans le transport collectif
mardi matin un site internet et une
pétition a été mise en ligne pour
sensibiliser la population et forcé le
gouvernement legault a reculé selon les
organisateurs construire de nouvelles
routes ne fera qu'empirer les problèmes
de congestion au sortir de la pandémie
la mobilité durable c'est prendre des
gens qui sont dans l'auto solo les
amener vers d'autres modes de transport
sont meilleurs pour l'environnement
meilleur pour les finances du québec
donc on est complètement à côté de la
plaque avec la troisième c'est sûr c'est
sûr que ça va aider l'économie
pour les 50 cent prochaines années pour
la chambre économique de québec par
contre les retombées positives du projet
sont trop importantes pour être ignorée
la circulation des biens et des
personnes entre les deux rives du fleuve
est grandement compliquée par la
présence de deux seuls pont dans le
secteur ouest
le bouclage des réseaux routiers et de
transports collectifs dans l'est est une
nécessité
moi ce que j'aime là dedans et légendes
à faire ce qu'ils aiment c'est la vision
à long terme
ça amène de nouveaux choix de nouvelles
options c'est un projet de mobilité
très bien m'intégrer à travers tous les
modes cet investisseur immobilier crois
que la sortie du tunnel dans le secteur
vanier contribuera à accélérer la
revitalisation du quartier ici olivier
lemieux radio canada québec